[Musique]
bonjour j stand jarno bonjour messieurs
via le temps secrétaire générale de la
cgtm et demandons que jeudi il y à cet
appel de plusieurs organisations
politiques de gauche essentiellement des
centrales syndicales dont la vôtre
la cgt m une mobilisation nationale est
ici en martinique contre thème central
la casse des services publics j'ai c'est
de l'acharnement contre la casse des
services publics le démantèlement des
services publics et aussi contre toute
la politique de monsieur macro qui ne
cesse d'attaquer les travailleurs pour
tous vos toujours enrichir les mêmes
personnes celui seul qui est responsable
bah il au service du patronat et c'est
le patronat qui dirige toute la société
ici comme ailleurs est donc cette
politique au service du patronat des
conséquences sur les salariés qui ont
des conditions de travail et que ces
crabes et qui contribua en fait qui
sombre qui contribuent à la richesse de
toutes ces personnes si j'ai bonne
mémoire il ya quelques mois alors qu'il
y avait un autre président il y avait
des appels à la grève sur ce même thème
et auparavant avant france avant
françois hollande il y avait nicolas
sarkozy il y avait également des appels
de ce genre ça veut dire que les
gouvernements passent mais se
ressemblent
vous l'avez dit vous-même c'est
exactement du pas sûr que je vous l'avez
dit vous-même c'est exactement ça et
tous les gouvernements dans le cadre de
la société actuelle sont des
gouvernements au service des forces pour
des forces sociales qui ont le pouvoir
économique
les forces sociales qui ont le pouvoir
économique c'est le patronat la
bourgeoisie exactement la même chose
pour une fois la gauche au travers de
son histoire a trahi et un peu son
programme si vous voulez donc c'est
loupé la gauche selon la chance je sais
pas mais c'est le pouvoir qui changent
vous savez dans la vie moi j'ai commencé
à militer très jeune et je compte bien
continuer à militer j'ai pas varié du
point de vue de vue fondamental de mes
idées parce que la société est toujours
la même c'est toujours une société au
niveau au profit des riches des
exploiteurs et puis il ya les salariés
qui sont obligés de travailler pour
vivre et dans cette société avec ses
services publics
qu'ils devraient des services au service
de la population
les différents gouvernements de droite
et de gauche ont toujours une politique
pour caceres public il ya peut-être
travail de formation à faire auprès de
de ces personnes lorsqu'elles sont tout
simplement candidat à une telle élection
n'ont pas ni pièces travail comme
m'arrêter là tout c'est mon état là
c'est qu'après tout c'est mon talent
yoni enjeux intellectuels à disposition
ue et qui cas et d'elyo à coup une épée
plat c'est ça la réalité le pouvoir
il a toute une série de gens qui sont à
leur disposition
la classe ouvrière les travailleurs les
exploiter les retraités les jeunes les
chômeurs ils doivent se démerder pour
vivre et c'est vrai qu'une petite
minorité d'intellectuels qui apportent
leur savoir leurs connaissances à ceux
qui souffrent dans la société
transformer le service public en
entreprise du cac 40 c'est ce que disent
ceux qui appellent à cette mobilisation
de demain mais je sais pas si on allait
transformer en entreprises du cac 40
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que ils ont fait combien d'argent
93 milliards vous vous rendez compte au
cap 4 93 milliards un gag capitaliste
comme bernard arnault
il a eu comme bénéfices l'année 2010 est
20 milliards d'euros
monsieur maquereau a décidé de supprimer
l'impôt sous la grosse fortune de 4 5
milliards d euros tout ça permettrait de
régler bien des problèmes dans les
services mais l'autre fait qui je
conseille dans son établissement
alors quand à ça je travaille dans un
établissement qui s'appelle le chum de
la martinique qui lie à qui a des dettes
importantes ça fait des années qu'on
demande aux gouvernements à tous ces
gouvernements qui se sont succédés
d'effacer les dettes du chum pour que
l'on puisse repartir sur de bons pieds
mais jusqu'ici ce n'est pas fait sauf
que si on s'appelait dexia on n'aurait
pas eu de problème pour voir nous dettes
effacées en une nuit
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement français le
gouvernement belge il ya quelques années
revenons sur cette histoire de retraités
considérés comme des privilèges
j ai par l'actuel pouvoir en plein en
place selon certains mecs et
déclarations de certains ministres on a
parlé de cette augmentation de la
contribution sociale généralisée qui
allait plomber le pouvoir d'achat de nos
aînés et hier ce gouvernement a semblé
faire un peu marche arrière en annonçant
que ceux qui sont à peine au dessus de
certains seuils ne seraient pas
concernés finalement par cette hausse de
27% en tout cas la semaine dernière le
jeudi 15 cgt m appelait les retraités
les travailleurs du secteur
médico-social à faire grève même si ça
pas une très grande couverture
médiatique ici et il ya eu le témoignage
de plusieurs autres étaient dans cette
camarade femme qui a pris la parole pour
dire l'augmentation de la csg
ça lui coûte 50 euros et ses 50 euros
comment elle va faire
est-ce qu'elle va décider de rester une
semaine elle vit seule est-ce qu'elle va
d'essayer de rester une semaine sans
manger
nous l'avons tué sur les ondes de la
première entendue sur les zones ne le
sait très bien et alors ce que je dis
c'est que c'est une réalité
ceux qui prennent de telles décisions
ils ne se rendent pas compte des
conditions dans lesquelles vivent
l'immense majorité de la population et
la l'immense majorité des personnes qui
sont en retraite aujourd'hui ont des
pensions extrêmement ténus et pourtant
ce sont des gens qui ont contribué à
enrichir ceux qui sont servis par
monsieur mac ou mais ça veut dire aussi
que le gouvernement peut reculer si le
versus a reculé de 7 ans plus tôt de la
csg ans et ne compte qu'ils pourraient
ne plus concerner à peu près une
centaine de milliers de personnes
le gouvernement va reculer si un rapport
de force conséquent quand on est salarié
quand on est pauvre quand on est quand
on fait partie du monde du travail le
gouvernement recule quand il y un
rapport de force quand on exploite
heures il suffit de donner un coup de
fil et puis on and on en gagne surtout
au niveau des exploiteurs les plus
riches alors le secteur de la santé de
la pause l'éducation nationale des
collectivités sont concernées le public
le parapublic
vous pensez que les martiniquais vont
descendre en masse dans les rues demain
en tout cas mon organisation la cgtm
nous appelons
l'ensemble de la population laborieuse à
y participer à ce mouvement parce que
les services publics si vous voulez
justement la population laborieuse elle
fréquente les services publics et quand
les prestations des services publics
sont de moins bonne qualité et bien ça
se retourne contre la population
quand la population va à l'hôpital et
que la renvoie à trois mois pour un
examen
quand elle va à l'hôpital qu'elle fait
son examen et qu'on lui dit qu'on peut
pas lui donner des résultats
parce qu'il n'ya pas de papiers parce
que l'hôpital n'a pas piller les dettes
des fournisseurs ok voix c'est ça la
réalité aujourd'hui
le chum droit 150 millions aux
fournisseurs et aujourd'hui chaque fois
qu'il manque des choses à l'hôpital on
nous dit les fournisseurs ne sont pas
payées on ne peut pas travailler comme
ça et c'est pour cela que le collectif
chum doux vent doux vent qu est partie
prenante de l'association sauvez la
santé en martinique appellent l ensemble
des travailleurs du secteur santé à être
dans la rue en tenue de travail
on demande à la population d'être
solidaire de son action en portant un
vêtement blanc madame lochard nos cette
dégradation des services publics comme
vous le dites est ce que ce n'est pas
quelque chose de purement subjectif et
que vous décrivez comme cela parce que
vous êtes dans une organisation
syndicale et que votre rôle aussi c'est
de demander toujours plus mais en face
on peut vous parler de rationalisation
des moyens d'efficacité à ces politiques
patrons qui concerne le cas pas les
nationalisations moyens parce que les
salariés quand il son travail quand ils
voient des choses anormales
ils disent ils ouvrent leur bouche ils
disent il faut améliorer il faut faire
de telle manière et c'est là on n'écoute
pas ce qu'ils disent et après on
découvre si vous voulez je donne
l'exemple inquiets plus macro ça fait
plus de quatre ans qu'on dit à la
direction de l'hôpital à une des
directions que la blanchisserie fallait
la changer parce qu'elles étaient
obsolètes ils ont le gouvernement a dit
non il faut externalisés et tous les
directeurs qui se sont succédé puisqu'on
a eu plusieurs dans cette période
eh ben ils ont cherché quelle est
l'entreprise sur le territoire de la
martinique qui peut traiter le tonnage
de lège du chum
ils n'en n'ont pas trouvé après indien
des facs et analyses à moitié ils n'en
n'ont pas trop
v aujourd'hui la blanchisserie ça fait
des frappes plusieurs fois qu'elle tombe
en panne un mois donc il faut acheter du
linge de table
il faut donner un petit peu aussi
entreprises qui peuvent
ça fait quatre ans après ils ont fait
venir des spécialistes ou étudier qui
ont dit qu'il faut refaire la
blanchisserie
mais ça fait quatre ans que les
travailleurs avaient déjà dit ça ce qui
est vrai pour cette blanchisserie au
niveau du chu de martini est vrai dans
de nombreux domaines mais les dirigeants
n'écoute pas les salariés
il n'écoute pas les salariés quel que
soit leur grade
y compris quand ce sont des médecins y
compris quand ce sont des cadres c'est
ce qu'ils ont décidé et appliquent
bêtement ce que dit le ministère et ils
ne prennent pas de risques aux salariés
va prendre des 10 qui va descendre dans
la rue mais les gens quand ils ont une
fonction de responsable
ils n'osent pas descendre dans la rue
qui s'acquittaient riz bio bio c'est
damon signe en éthique sioca des fon
sayo cadillac yo té pou des saunas larry
qu'on travaillait qui exécutent aux
cadets sens de la vie et les loups
qu'ils comprennent ça en lobag a été
changé les uk respecter tout
travaillaient quel que soit grandiose
hélène optique en grade la peau en baggy
comprenons aussi cinq grades l'avait
tabarot baghai grade là sa vraie fokine
icade savait faux ce qu'il nie médecins
savent riffaud qui nie tout cas témoin
qui a organisé et fauque unity lomé ya
aussi des cas travail mais si un chat y
tout moment la riaa der mais j'ai dit
wendel et puis c'était bon matin s'est
agi seul chercheur arnaud secrétaire
général de l'acim en vue de cette brève
mobilisation annoncée demain un fort de
france merci bonne journée
[Musique]